[Music]
and too young for what the hell is B
smell if I rose B girl who does the
audience time or seeking plastic surgery
because they hate the way their vagina
looks at all nine year old wait till
they [ __ ] have a baby that she's
going to have to parent is saying yes
I'm going to [ __ ] show up those lips
what do we call the judges with
vaginoplasty that was actually called
maybe a plastic house do these nine year
olds even know options like how do they
even know what to compare their vagina
lips are you I know
no to make them feel insecure about the
ova job you mean you're talking about
that these yeah the cartons the predator
face because at nine your body isn't
fully developed yet
yeah but that means that also means that
they've been looking at other vaginas to
know that they don't like their own
because I know home girls that haven't
even seen their own vagina so they were
like at least in there like 14 or 15 I
don't know what my [ __ ] looks like then
you guys have to get a mirror [ __ ] you
know look at that stuff yeah so yeah
labiaplasty is a plastic surgery to
alter the appearance of the outer labia
in the vagina so who's their parents are
saying okay we'll get you some [ __ ]
vagina surgery I don't know it's
apparent how do I even bring that up
mom oh oh patrasche you know
and then mom looks at it oh damn [ __ ]
that's the Mosby [ __ ] we gotta go get
surgery on this [ __ ] is that
what's happening that's right you got a
straw me down there these are some open
kids because I think even if I was a kid
and I had an insecurity like that I
wouldn't know how to bring that up to my
parents and I asked my boss all my other
friends dicks and I was like how come
your dick is different from mine because
we would all go like to Pete like we
would like to go pee together now I
understand why my dick is different and
I asked my parents and all they're like
oh they're circumcised and you're not
and I was like I want to be circumcised
and I'm glad I did it because I like to
keep my feelers sensitive must be loose
yeah I know I was thinking the same
thing till my town they're really like
open with their parents because me I
remember I think I was like 7 or 8 years
old and I remember being like I had this
stomach ache like I was just it was
hurting my side so much and I went to my
mom I was like mom I stomach hurt so I
picked up pregnant and she was like well
are you constipated all the good that
means you like have you pooped and I was
so shy and I couldn't tell her that no I
haven't pooped okay yeah I have issues
like for you guys and what's wrong and
I'm like I don't know it hurts and then
she'll feel a big ol bulge of like crap
on my stomach and I'm like I feel all
the wrinkles all Rocky's yeah
whatever they're not ridges are like a
corn here and then she ended up figuring
it out that I was like a baby book and I
was constipated but yeah it was like so
shy I couldn't sandy you couldn't tell
your mom you couldn't I couldn't that's
so odd like I don't know why at that age
kids are carrying what the [ __ ] they
look like I don't think I give a [ __ ]
what I look like at that age I was
walking around doing whatever what
country this so this is happening in the
UK and so the National Health Service or
NHS they reported that between 2015 and
2016 there were more than 200 girls
under the age of 18 that had labiaplasty
died and 150 of them were under the age
of 15 Wow with what parents are saying
yes to
[ __ ] and like who the [ __ ] like I think
they do have [ __ ] up [ __ ] though no
because there was a there wasn't one
doctor that was reporting that she gets
young girls in her in her office every
week and saying that they just hate the
way the vagina looks like they just want
to hook it in like a Barbie they don't
want to have anything sticking out Oh
Barbie doesn't even have a [ __ ] exactly
Barbie the [ __ ] just a [ __ ] grandma
underwear why do they thing like when
guys are about to [ __ ] them like I don't
know I don't think that's going to
happen at all they [ __ ] earlier out
there that way I know like when they're
eight wait so are they going in getting
surgery on their own without their
parents consent that's the part I don't
know like I was curious too I wanted to
find out what are these parents doing
hardly letting them get go through with
this there's no reports on the parents
side of it they probably got ugly as
[ __ ] because somewhat the mom or
someone has to have to be okay with it
so the moms probably checking that [ __ ]
and be like girl your [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like a [ __ ] man
what happened did somebody [ __ ] do
jiu-jitsu on your clitoris or some [ __ ]
reasons I looked at it or maybe it's
what's in style you know like when were
a kid like everyone got braces and so
now people don't give a [ __ ] about
braces and everyone's just during PE
just showing each other their vaginas so
but oh you got that new vagina let me do
my vagina everyone's just doing their
vagina together I would love for my kid
that come up to me and talk about that
[ __ ] because I'll slap them in the
[ __ ] face so you guys that's not
something you need to be worrying about
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] it the [ __ ] out of
my face I love you but or like maybe
what is the parents like done it
themselves too like when they were
younger and so when they're kids
bringing out their more delightful this
is new technology though so it's like
though the parents just got hurt she
just got vagina surgery and then she's
like mother-daughter fun time let's both
get matching vagina wish monkey I don't
even know how these girls are going
through with your surgeries because
they're saying that it's medically
inadvisable for girls go to these
algebra team to get this surgery because
they're not even fully developed
yeah what nobody left but you need those
[ __ ] flaps those are the girls
fielder's yeah it's the same skin that
the male scrotum is made out of I'll
know about that
I think the [ __ ] is the most sensitive
right yeah but still why would you don't
understand man like sometimes it doesn't
look good but it feels better it's all
about feel there was this one girl I was
being interviewed that she said when she
was 14 she thought that she wanted to
get the surgery but now she's in her
mid-twenties and she's glad she didn't
do it and she's a bit quote I guess I
would just picked up from somewhere that
it wasn't neat enough or tidy enough and
I think I wanted it to be smaller
sometimes people around me were watching
porn and stuff and I just had this idea
that it should be symmetrical and not
sticking out I thought that's what
everyone else looks like you might just
grow into your labia you know some
people that grow into their ears they
grow into their nose and if you have
these [ __ ] dangling eyes labia well
if you're [ __ ] 4 or 5 of course going
to be [ __ ] down here on the floor but
when you grow into like five five or
something is an adoring thing
what didn't grow into your labia it's
like you've grown into ears you got big
ears when you're a kid but when you grow
up maybe your skull grows into I think
you just shouldn't give a [ __ ] about
stupid [ __ ] now worry about your [ __ ]
multiplications and your division you
dumb [ __ ]
maybe worry about getting a job yes
getting good grades man if my kid comes
up and did some stupid [ __ ] like that I
can't wait dude I just want them to like
nothing I think boys I think boys do the
same [ __ ] though it's like we were doing
Astra fields every [ __ ] day we would
get a question is my dick big enough oh
it's my big big enough that's us do what
the [ __ ] man that's tough that's like
the least of your worries man girls
don't think like guys I think it's a
common like insecurity though because I
remember when I was first on my vagina
thinking like what the [ __ ] is that how
it's supposed to look like like am i
normal like so I understand I get I can
relate to how they're feeling but I
never thought like I'm going to get
through drew on this [ __ ] I'm just
amazed that all the parents that deaf
sign up that signed off on this is the
part that's crazy after so many parents
why yep that's an issue going into these
adolescent
mine's right like do you think is it one
of those Oh my future husband I don't
want him to [ __ ] be grossed out is it
one of those things or is it like a
personal thing where it's like I don't
want my [ __ ] let's be looking like
hamburger when I put a bikini on here's
a combination of those at least that's
how I want a camel toe that's how it is
for me with my insecurities and when I
thought of that like that thought
crossed my mind like oh [ __ ] my vagina
is this how it should look because I had
never seen any other vaginas I didn't
know what they should look like as long
as it's not a [ __ ] big as big why if
you're like if you're like this in your
legs if you saw my vagina supposed to
look probably might be well I think when
I mean is like I never saw vaginas
either and then when I saw mine I was
just like okay that's what it's supposed
to look like but then once I started
like being with guys like I never once
thought about it being weird or like I
just thought it looked weird but then
the way guys would speak about vaginas I
was just like oh okay well I tell ya
that's what I like that and then when I
started having sex or whatever like I
never bought anything here without [ __ ]
shamed I have never ever by the time a
guy finally gets to touch or feel or see
or vagina that shit's like heaven on are
a [ __ ] shiny people would I would hang
out like with my friends and then
they're just always talking about [ __ ]
and how good and I'm just like okay yeah
doesn't matter what looks like there's
no stick it in no that's not it that's
just a [ __ ] hairy oyster I think from
you when I was younger I never was aware
that that like a vagina would have lips
until like I guess like mine started
growing and then like a part of it would
start chasing I guess my underwear and
it kind of be a little bit painful and
all this what the [ __ ] is this at all
like why duty what did you order it no
yes stop wearing [ __ ] Kevlar
underwear I don't know you guys know
your girl I remember one
- I felt like that to our own like what
the [ __ ] yeah so she chased cuz I was so
young and I guess just it didn't have
that like environment down there yet so
it was kind of like it felt a little
creepy
yeah watching where softer underwear
underwear of us take the friction you
talk yeah it was the restriction that
happened all back to me like what the
[ __ ] is going on right you some dumb 840
for the longest time I was like making
out like oh [ __ ] dude like what if my
vagina's not the right time to vagina
chopped off do it like I'm like becoming
a mutant or something cuz like I didn't
know what that what the hell is
happening until I grader in school I
learned like oh yeah you got to lift
that cover your vagina I'm like also
this is natural so the natural is a
heavy rope but I didn't know it you got
a folding yeah oh that's true because
when your [ __ ] babies just a line
yeah the macaroon that's it
this is a [ __ ] baby vagina right here
that way
I'm so confused what else what else
happened then people realized oh well it
grows and it turns into alley
no one's not an alley you know mine
stays like this so I'm gonna go yeah
some girls turn into out early
everyone's vaginas different yeah yeah
yeah I know that but I just didn't
understand what you guys were saying but
now I get it it's almost different yeah
I guess that's what these girls are
going through and they feel that they
need to go through surgery which is
really sad I don't think so yeah I mean
the doctor was saying that you people
that get labiaplasty it's only it's to
fix any like defects or medical
abnormalities that they have alright if
they have like intersex conditions like
and that makes sense whatever you guys
experienced is probably what these girls
are experiencing it and if it was
painful then now I get it
no but they're just treating it as if
it's a permanent issue when they even
grow into them yet job I think if
they're like 25 and then they'll like
dragon on the floor then yeah but and
you grew into yours that what you're
saying because I wasn't exactly sure how
to bring it up to like even my parents
or to anybody because for the longest
time like all [ __ ] did I have like such
a perform for Giants like I don't even
know what to think of it right yeah but
then when I learned in school I was like
okay so this is normal this is like
natural so then like after a while like
I just learned to just deal with she's a
gold mom would it would stop trading or
it would hurt and you're just like oh
what is she gonna after a while it did
because like I don't know I think my
body just grew into it I do how do you
do cross country [ __ ] well I would
mind you burning or vagina all day long
but why that time in high school it
didn't it didn't hurt like I say I think
it's really because that made me bring
the attention that I have lips down
there and I was like I don't know what
these lips are for me it was I I
realized what the chafing was because I
was wearing underwear they're already
too small for me it was like to dig or
silver freaking wedgie all day yeah so
thank you
I just picture the cutest of go into
work yeah so girls out there don't be
self-conscious or your vagina turn
normal your [ __ ] is fine hey guys
thanks for watching if you guys enjoyed
that episode please let us know in the
comments below and share your thoughts I
liked it so much oh I wish they talked
about this and this just let us know in
the comments for more videos click right
up here
[Music]